[Musik]
die sind wie explodiert
und wenn man da unten
ich habe
[Musik]
blind es wird wärmer
Strumpfhose selbstständig
wie gelingt ein gutes Leben auch mit
Behinderung davon handelt dieser Film
guten Morgen
es ist gut
Andrea Schläfli ist früh unterwegs so
hat sie genügend Zeit um den Weg zu
ihrem heutigen Arbeitsort zu finden
wie orientieren Sie sich also für mich
ist Leben ganz wichtiges Memory Spiel
und und da bin ich ziemlich unsicher
aber wenn ich
muss ab 2 gesucht also was heißt
ja wir so erinnere wo Gott ungefähr
und das hilft mir aber schon dass ich
nur entspannt bin zum das machen
wenn ich es gar nicht weiß würde ich
nervös wie verrückt
was sie wirklich gesagt
also ich sehe auf einmal gar nicht und
auf dem anderen auch gesehen
ich kann ein signalstock der
vor allem gesehen dass ich sie nicht
gesehen
das auftritts- und
Kommunikationstrainerin heute bei der
Gebäudeversicherung des Kantons Zürich
diese Tätigkeit hat sich schon ausgeübt
als sie noch gesehen hat
auf die Idee behindert sind das Chöre
ich sehr häufig das Kirche
ja was ist das Training oder
vielleicht da ganz feststellen so und
und wenn ich wenn ich einen Ruhm wird
abscannt
heute
trainiert
aus dem Kanton Zürich
kriegt es Gewicht ist
vom Idealfall also dort variiere zahlen
ist spitzerli aber von ungefähr sechs
Prozent
oder so ja genau
Kombination genau
so schnell blendet und und wenn ich
nicht einfach alles Nomen an der Fassade
habt keine den den nehme
[Musik]
Andreas Schläfli lebt in Winterthur sie
ist Single und führt ihren Haushalt
allein
[Musik]
das immer überall alles am gleichen
für mich ist ganz schlimm wenn nicht
aber ja Mensch gibt es also zwei
drei mal im Jahr und ihre Freundin
Andrea Schläfli lebt ohne IV Rente sie
will sich ihren Lebensunterhalt selbst
verdienen
jedes Mal wenn es formuliert so Sachen
[Musik]
Andrea schläflis Leben mit
Sehbehinderung begann vor bald zehn
Jahren in einer Augustnacht waren ihre
Sehnerven richtig gehend explodiert ich
bin deta
gesagt du ich gesehen
rückblickend
diese Art der Erblindung ist äußerst
selten ihr Ärzte staunten darum vor
allem über die medizinische Sensation
ohne Andrea Schläfli jedoch zu helfen
diese musste zusehen wie er sie vermögen
mehr und mehr zurückgehen
ich habe mich erinnere
und den Abwechslung
gemacht haben und wie angefangen hat
gestern
und halt über die Woche hinweg gelebt
hat bis ich irgendwann mit dem linken so
[Musik]
Angst gehabt und irgendwann habe ich
einfach nicht
für Wasser
Andrea Schläfli suchte Hilfe in
alternativen Heilmethoden und reiste in
eine ayurvedische Augenklinik in Indien
dort konnte man das Fortschreiten der
Erblindung zwar stoppen ihr sie vermögen
kam aber auch dort nicht zurück in dem
Spital
irgendwie unterwegs
und der hat die wunderbare Jahre
Gewohnheit Partner sehr
einmal im Tag ist er sicher wie ihrem
Zimmer gestanden
ich glaube ich eine
nähkühleralisieren Zimmer
[Musik]
und er hat einfach nicht
dieser alte Arzt sollte an Andrea
Schläfli noch ein wundervollbringen doch
davon später
Andrea Schläfli bewegt sich versiert im
öffentlichen Raum aber sie sei stets
etwas am hochstapeln sagt sie mir also
ganz viele von uns bemüht sich natürlich
wahnsinnig zum Sachen auswendig lernen
und den wirkt haben
und ich weiß wirklich nicht wo das der
Schalter ist und ich würde mir das
wünschen dass
im Osten
genau aber es leider nicht dermaßen
können Sie mir helfen den Schalter zu
finden
sind oder und alles das wo ihr
geforderte Tisch nämlich dass mir
selbstständig könnt mir betroffene
Menschen das ist ständig
das ist jetzt könnt ihr mir sagen
danke viel mal danke viel mal
Entschuldigung
entschuldigung darf ich sie nicht stören
genau das ist Schleuderer ganz vielen
Links zu rufen
ich merke ich finde es anstrengend und
und er verwendet so einen Moment und
wenn einem Auto auf die Blume bei den
normalen
ist passiert eigentlich so
und und weiß zwar dass die Leute
eigentlich
so schlimm
zurück zum alten Arzt in Indien
ja irgendwann hatträumig sind you must
happy also ich bin
katere mit mir mit dem Leben
mit anderen Abschied von ich vermisse
nee und so und
der Stadt
was andere im Vorbeigehen machen ist für
die 52-Jährige ein Spießrutenlauf
da wird kalt da hat Joghurt oder so es
wird wärmer
ja ja
Strumpfhosen kaufen im Supermarkt zum
Beispiel mit ihrer Mutter hat sie den
Laden einen ganzen Vormittag lang
rekognostiert
[Musik]
eben es gibt so eine Sohnes App das
heißt sie in AI das ist also sing ein
und artificial intelligence
und das tut Süd vorlesen
Strumpfhose Enkel Start wohl Enkel
entwickelt
und das ist was für Referat
eventuell für mich schlecht
[Gelächter]
Flecken
empfangen
natürlich Schule Wunsch
dass man nicht irgendwie so einfach
abkürzt aus gesehen oder will ich möchte
nach wie vor im puffsleben unterwegs
sind und so und dann ist mir schon
wichtig ist
[Musik]
und mich selbst Mitleid und der muss
doch verstorben der kann doch nicht
zeigen ich muss jetzt einfach glücklich
sie so und das Spiele happy jeder Tag
macht
Sekundarlehrerin Theaterpädagogin
Kulturmanagerin bei ihrer
wissenschaftlichen Arbeit muss ihr höher
sind den sie sind weitgehend ersetzen
unendliche Augenblick das ist das Buch
in der Maxime der Aufklärung
es braucht recht viel Konzentration
machen
und da muss ich mir vor allem sehr
präzise geschrieben wenn oder Willi
Textstellen finde ich wichtig da muss
ich mir irgendwie Minuten aufschreiben
weil es Kapitel und dann gebe ich das
die gleiche Person wo eben auch so
lektoratsache macht für mich
die Stelle Personen
und das mache ich partiell auch aber so
eine ganze Publikation
ist das für mich einfach so unglaublich
anstrengend wenn ich jetzt das
eigentlich eh nur so
also doch haben wir Vergrößerung
Stift markieren wenn ich möchte markiere
aber ich muss sagen das ganzes Buch so
lesen finde ich sehr anstrengend Zürich
Ende Oktober 2022 Menschen mit
Behinderung tauschen sich mit vertreten
der kantonalen Verwaltung aus
[Musik]
2014 hat die Schweiz die UNO
Behindertenrechtskonvention
unterzeichnet umgesetzt wurde davon
wenig
Konventionen berücksichtigen also das
ist
Fotos
integriert werden und und und
letzte Woche bin ich auf einer Webseite
ich bin kein Roboter und den taktisches
Fenster aufgegangen und dann sind
auf dem bildschirmmaschine man müsste ja
klicken auf Fußgänger
Selbstständigkeit
einfach kein Gedanke treffen
Moderatorin der sogenannten
partizipationskonferenz des Kantons
Zürich ist Andreas Schläfli
kantonalen verwaltet schaffe also für
öffentliche
aufgabenverantwortlich ziehen
moderieren
dialogförderer zwischen verschiedenen
Disziplinen zwischen
verwaltungsstätten und betroffen und wir
brauchen
Behinderung und Andreas Schläfli
verstaut
[Applaus]
miteinander ich freue mich unglaublich
dass ich heute Nachmittag mit Ihnen hier
sein darf wir alle wissen es gibt so
viele Fragestellungen die jetzt für den
Kanton Zürich zu lösen sind die für jede
Gemeinde zu lösen sein werden und es ist
an uns da den Impuls zu geben für
kreative Lösungen für inspirierte
Lösungen für Möglichkeiten die
hoffentlich gegangen
und je länger bis es Dunkelheit umso
mehr
lichtigkeit jetzt mehr Geld das ziemlich
verrückt
auf jeden Fall ist der wunderbare Tag
und der magische momento
von ihrem Zimmer
[Musik]
so schön mit ihrer Freundin Doris
Stalder teilt Andreas schläfl ihre
Begeisterung fürs Wandern
Doris Stalder ist medizinisch gesehen
blind hat aber noch einen minimalen
serrest
igt fotografieren
ich glaube wirklich oder die Orte
der ist eigentlich der Abgrund für mich
gar nicht richtig und was ist jetzt
Vergnügen für sie beide also
wirklich laufen wegschnaufen
einfach in der Natur sie und merke wie
wie die Bewegung in der Natur wie Design
einfach auf schwarz
Doris Stalder arbeitet als medizinische
Masseurin hat mit 50 ein
Soziologiestudium absolviert vertandem
und spielt Golf
für was
erste Begegnung machen
[Musik]
möglichst viel positivsten
und
meinst du deutsche überhaupt einzelne
Match gerne die Kinder rum Cappy ist
ja
sieben Jahre arbeitete Andrea schläferi
als kulturvermittlerin bei der Stadt
Winterthur 2016 kündigte sie frustriert
mit dem Schriftzug Superblock hatten
ich finde es unglaublich schlimm dass
ein öffentliche Verwaltung
im Jahr 2015
gerne hätte ich gefilmt wie Andrea
Schläfli und der Winterthurer
Stadtpräsident diese Frage diskutieren
doch dieser will mich nur ohne seine
ehemalige Angestellte empfangen der
Vorwurf kann ich ganz verstanden dass
der Bau ist eigentlich von der
grundeigentümerie
gemacht Mitgliedern
behindertenkonferenz Kanton Zürich
geleitet also ich denke mir hat reagiert
darauf dass er mir gefunden hat da haben
wir neu verbessern und ein gewissem
Maßnahmen ergriffen und von damals
wirklich gesagt beende Behinderte
gerecht es ist Verwaltungsgebäude
trotz Nachbesserungen beim
Blindenleitsystem zum Beispiel besteht
auch heute noch Handlungsbedarf
da müssen
merkt wenn man da ausstiegt oder da
wartet dass man wirklich auf der Bus
runter
und da vorne ist eben die Linie die
gehört einfach hoch also die müssen die
da ganz sicher also letztlich müsst ihr
Bushaltestelle führen
aber es ist völlig unklar wieso da
einfach aufhört
einfach nicht
aber jetzt Frau schlafli es sind vier
Prozent Sehbehinderte in der Schweizer
Bevölkerung
frag nach der Verhältnismäßigkeit ja die
finde ich persönlich ganz schwierig will
ich sie als zynische empfinden
ob jetzt die fünf Meter wo das sind noch
so unglaublich viel mehr
ihre Erfahrungen bei der Stadt
Winterthur Schmerzen Andreas Schläfli
bis heute kriegt man natürlich so sehr
gewünscht dass zum Beispiel irgendein
Kopierer zur Verfügung
vom Bereich Kultur immer Muskeln kannst
du mir bitte helfen kopieren oder kannst
du mir bitte helfen scannen oder wie
immer und sie hat das mit unendliche
Liebe und geduldig gemacht habe das
Bedürfnis selber milliar bekommen
selbstständig
bereit ja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
manchmal ist das Make-up frustrierend
und denkt man also hin und her Christi
ja
ja oder ist es wirksam wenn ich mich
wieder hier
so entscheidend
und sich selber zwischen dienen Aussage
und zeige auf
Zeit
[Musik]
dass das Happy wirklich und
irgendwie ganz bewusst danke für alles
und ich habe
[Musik]